Raphaël Enthoven que vous voyez ici à
affronter chat GPT lors de l'épreuve de
bac de philo 2023 je vais parler du
bonheur le bonheur est-il affaire de
raison mais alors c'est pas un défi que
je me suis lancé c'est un défi qu'on m'a
lancé
et en vérité je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment un défi pour la petite histoire
bien sûr sur le GPD a déjà fini son sa
copie donc on est en train de voilà
retranscrire la copie en mode manuscrite
est meilleur que 99% des étudiants au
passage du Barou au concours de
Polytechnique au concours de
l'agrégation de maths de physique faites
le passé l'épreuve de maths sup ou de
maths spé ou des concours de NS il
défoncera et pardon il battre n'importe
quel étudiant dans la copie de Tchad
jppy il y a même pas de problématiques
et puis c'est souvent des très longues
phrases assez creuses finalement où il y
a pas vraiment de contenu ou on comprend
pas vraiment les arguments les notes 11
et 20 voilà sur de la motive ou le
cheval lequel est le moyen de transport
le plus élégant non sans moque la
question c'est alors lequel est le plus
rapide lequel permettra d'aller voir le
plus de performance alors oui cet objet
pété dans la tête pas la grec de
philosophie il sera capable d'envoyer
des fusées sur la Lune nous sommes
consoles de la note que j'ai eu au bac
j'avais eu 11 au bac et enfin j'ai pété
à l'époque pas du tout j'avais eu peur
comme tout le monde et voilà je vais
sans régler
folie vu les usages
et d'ailleurs on voit qu'il y a un débat
mondial qui s'installe sur la nécessité
de réguler l'intelligence artificielle
qu'elle soit négative ou même dans ces
usages industriels le fond Marianne
c'était son idée mais depuis les
premières révélations Marlène Schiappa
s'était fait discrète la voici sous
serment pour répondre sénateurs sur la
gestion de ce fond au cœur d'une
commission d'enquête sénatoriale je me
dérempage je suis là devant vous et
j'entends endosser ma responsabilité
toute ma responsabilité pardon pour la
formulation mais aussi rien que ma
responsabilité c'est pas de commentaire
à faire sur le l'audition de toute façon
plus générale il y a pas de commentaires
du gouvernement à faire sur le travail
des parlementaires lorsqu'ils font une
commission d'enquête et encore moins sur
le travail de la justice lorsqu'elle est
lorsqu'elle est saisie donc j'ai pas
davantage de commentaires à faire un
comité de sélection qui est mise en
place avec des membres de
l'administration et des membres de mon
cabinet moi je n'interviens pas
personnellement pour être tout à fait
honnête avec vous j'ai pas en tête la
totalité des noms ou des visages des
gens qui ont pris part à ce projet on
attend tout simplement la vérité que les
suspicions soient levées vous n'allez
pas comme certains jusqu'à demander son
retrait son départ du gouvernement moi
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas mon habitude
manifestement les membres de mon cabinet
tout comme le cipdr était en soutien de
l'initiative je ne sais pas je ne suis
pas en mesure de vous je ne connais pas
les échanges qui ont pu avoir lieu sur
ce sujet j'ai découvert cette affiche
s'affiche publiée sous l'égide de la
République française via le ministre de
la culture c'est fou et il écrit tous
ces étrangers qui ont fait l'histoire de
France Louis XIV le Roi Soleil illustre
ses mots sa grand-mère était
autrichienne sa mère espagnole si je
devine bien ce message qui n'est pas
subliminal Louis XIV et donc un étranger
c'est assez extraordinaire ce que vous
dites vous êtes en train de nous dire
qu'avec trois membres de votre cabinet
vous n'êtes au courant de rien sur
comment dirais-je une séquence de trois
semaines d'un fond Marianne dont vous
déclarez l'urgence à agir
il y a marqué mère espagnol et
grand-mère autrichienne ah oui alors en
plus ils se sont tombés donc le
ministère de la culture
des milliers de personnes sont présentes
donc cet après-midi pour ces funérailles
d'État c'est même un jour de deuil
national aujourd'hui en Italie
l'opposition s'en est émue d'ailleurs
c'était mieux de la décision du
gouvernement italien je vous rappelle
alors
vous êtes avachi dans le fauteuil vous
criez un peu fort honnêtement vous étiez
dans votre état normal bah bien sûr que
oui
c'est une drôle de question que vous me
posez Donald Trump devant un juge
fédéral qui lui a notifié les 37 charges
retenus contre lui l'ancien président
est poursuivi pour avoir conservé des
document top secret dans sa résidence
personnelle de Mara Lago en Floride mais
vous êtes en effet vous avez vu
l'attitude
je peux reconnaître quelque chose
peut-être que mon dos n'était pas assez
droit mais en revanche la colère elle
aucun souci sur ce sujet